depuis plusieurs jours le joueur
espagnol qui défend les couleurs de l'om
alvaro gonzalez est la cible de
nombreuses insultes sur les réseaux
sociaux il faut dire que depuis son
clash sur le terrain avec neymar
mi-septembre le joueur n'a rien fait
pour faire baisser la pression
accusé d'avoir proféré des insultes
racistes à l'encontre de neymar lors
d'une rencontre opposant le psg à l'om
ce dernier s'est toujours défendu de ce
dérapage si certains commentateurs
sportifs attesté que le joueur avait bel
et bien traités neymar de singe la
commission chargée de traiter la sphère
a décidé que les preuves n'étaient pas
assez fortes pour trancher
on a tous regardé messieurs on n'a rien
on n'a rien vu une affaire sur laquelle
le joueur s'est exprimé il ya quelques
jours en répondant pour la première fois
aux questions des transistors sur le
sujet et le moins que l'on puisse dire
c'est qu'il n'a pas cherché à calmer le
jeu j'ai été supérieure à neymar sur ce
match je l' ai sorti de son match d'où
son impuissance ce jour là il faut
savoir digérer les défaites savoir
perdre et savoir quand les choses ne
sont pas bien fait une réponse d'autant
plus étonnante que désormais neymar et
l'om club dans lequel joue alvaro
gonzalez ont tous les deux signé un
contrat avec la marque puma
une marque qui aurait demandé aux deux
champions de calmer le jeu pour ne pas
égratigner son image
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya une marque qui bien ce c'est miss
est entre guillemets parce qu'il ya des
gros sous en jeu quand même parce que ce
sont des sponsors qui vraiment est
important donc pas la solution ce serait
pas de suspension longue et ça
conviendrait du coup aux deux clubs
ennemis et ça conviendrait aussi à la
marque qui dit comme ça moi j'ai des
joueurs sur lesquels j'ai beaucoup
d'argent et du coup l'image n'est pas
écornée et munich est fan de l'om
oui je suis fan de l'om est en fait moi
j'ai essayé au maximum de ne pas du tout
parlé de cette histoire parce que
justement je n'ai rien vu on ne m'a pas
montré de vidéos d'un côté comme de
l'autre qui me prouve que alvaro d'un
côté a eu des progrès il dit
ils cherchent et de l'autre aussi ceux
dont on parle pas assez que neymar est
il des propos homophobes envers alvaro
et moi c'est ça le problème c'est que je
trouve qu'on s'est vraiment emballée et
notamment alvaro s'en est pris plein la
tête
le clan neymar a dévoilé son téléphone
son numéro de téléphone sur les réseaux
sociaux
à ce compte là où justement il révèle
avoir reçu que deux millions de messages
sur what's app parce que son numéro en
année sans viser quelqu'un madame sortie
non mais attends à ce qu elle me parlait
justement des insultes homophobes mais
on a quand même répondu non mais attends
une insulte homophobe ce cas les moins
graves qui n'assiste à sucre a choisi un
nom on va dire à fuir l'horreur n'est
d'accord après je comprends pas je
comprends puma parce que je pense que
puma se dit bon déjà il ya les contrats
bien sûr mais comme tout le monde en
fait on n'a pas de preuves
donc à un moment donné c'est soit tu tu
prends les deux tu leur donnes la même
sanction aux deux parce que sur les deux
il n'y a pas de preuves d'image vrai
réel soit tu ne fais rien du tout et
puis c'est surtout que c'est un faux
débat
je crois que vraiment ça c'est un faux
débat c'est un faux débat parce que si
on regarde chaque match de foot dont la
cpmc psg om cd clasico en avant tous les
matchs ici insulté sa mère faire la
tronche là on est sûr oui enfin mais là
les incidents graves si elles sont
avérées trop grave blessure c'est la
question c'est justement est-ce que vous
pensez que la marque cette marque là de
ce mode de sponsors a essayé d'étouffer
sa nouvelle survient la morale là dedans
par la wii puisque c'est tout et ils ont
tout à y gagner là-dedans bien sûr c'est
que les deux joueurs sont sous le tapis
meetic soul
en même temps il ya beaucoup trop
d'argent en jeu de danse grecque donc
c'est pour ça qu'en fait ils font tout
pour étouffer la faire pour qu'il n'y
ait pas de sanction pour alvaro uribe
pour neymar donc comme ça forcément si
je sors le terrain ils ont ils jouent
avec la marque opi et donc le lui j'ai
pu jouer là dessus j'ai envie de vous
dire qu'il marche surtout dans les pas
de la ligue parce que la ligue en a fait
autant disant ah bah écoute et aux non
pas demain - n'a pas réussi à comprendre
ce qu'on a vu sur les les bouches de
l'un et de l'autre
donc comme ça on ne punit personnes
maintenant pour revenir vite c'est sur
ce qu'a dit emilie je suis totalement
d'accord il n'y a pas de hiérarchisation
dans l'horreur juste je pense que ce que
la personne a essayé de faire comprendre
emilie et c'est quelque chose que l'on
décrit et c'est malheureux parce que ça
se fait depuis des années
il ya tout le temps beaucoup d' insulte
c'est à dire que même quand il ya des
insultes homophobes ce qui est ignoble
c'est indigne et ça ne se fait pas ce
sont des six est un délit c'est pas
juste une opinion c'est un délit
malheureusement on le fait auprès de
l'arbitré le soin auprès des juges de
touche on fait auprès de tout le monde
en fait alors que ce sont des personnes
dont la sexualité n'est pas avérée dans
les décors
rien à voir pour autant il faut il faut
faire un mais c'est grave absolument